no joke right now I'm thinking about
leaving like I don't know what I'm doing
here and what do you wanna go that's
what we were talking about taxes or I
don't know probably Texas maybe Florida
I think Texas the one I don't live in
Florida yeah I don't know why I don't
know that I want to live in Texas either
but like really I love this like the
idea that I would have to leave 85 and
sunny today we're in Santa Monica it's
perfect we can't go to the beach we've
got all of the worst types of people
running this state but our governor have
induces happened but isn't there this is
what leftism is isn't there a part of
you that wants to fight to stay though
there is a mom trust me that is where
I've been at the last 72 hours I have
been at that like internal thing
constantly like do you stay in fight
even though there's almost no evidence
that you can turn this thing around in
this state or do you just get out then
they win I feel like if we leave it like
look what you on must know you want you
want to do what all right I'm gonna take
my facility I'm out of it oh wow all
right all right you can open up use like
this I thought they opens that what
happened exactly
yeah they're letting him I guess they're
letting what do they do they're they're
letting the facility remain open or
something because they were gonna say
none of it can be open just
non-essential goods but then they they
went back on that said well you can open
but there has to be a limited number
number of people right necessary
precaution see the thing is that that
Gill girl um Eric Garcetti and Newsome
and all these people they that for a
while the California economy was doing
really well right before this
yeah we're crushed seems like a crazy
gamble to keep us shut down this long
why are they doing this so it depends
how far down the rabbit hole you want to
go let's go well so look look there's
the there's the literal version of this
which is okay maybe they know something
about Cody that they're not telling us
you know so maybe there that is but I
don't know about that it's like it's
like we crushed the curve nobody's sick
the idea that we really shouldn't be
doing this right now
hospitals are empty the only people that
are that with minor exceptions it's like
if you're over 80 and already sick
though those are the people are younger
obese have problems or what younger and
obese the younger okay so if we take all
of that stuff it's like that is not an
of a reason to keep all of us who are in
the prime of life away from our friends
from our family like I don't know about
you guys but I was thinking the other
day like I want to hug my mom my mom's
in New York but like this is crazy at
this point she's 70 she can't leave the
house basically so the rabbit hole
though would be if you want like that
answer it's that they genuinely want to
destroy the economy so the Trump loses
like my aim is that I I don't think it's
that crazy they threw everything at
Trump russia-ukraine this that the other
thing now there's all this Flynn stuff
leaking out that's gonna look really bad
for Obama and Biden and it's like maybe
that they really remember Bill Maher guy
who I really like in a lot of ways don't
forget this is a guy who two years ago
was talking about how if the economy
crashed if that's what it took to get
rid of Trump then that would be good
like I think a lot of lefties think like
that like they think Hitler's in charge
as bananas as that is and what would you
do to take out Hitler if you would ruin
everything point two percent
unemployment did they hell didn't notice
that we're full employment the I mean
it's they don't want to get Trump out
than any of that to them and and for
them they also don't believe in numbers
so it's like it doesn't matter how many
unemployed people are here cuz we'll
just make up money we'll just make up
money to give them and then you just
keep these people on the network
government programs yeah to fill in
we're private enterprise they love that
they love government programs no matter
how many times it keeps people in
perpetual poverty generation after
generation why I don't get why the
masses can't see the numbers and see
that it's gone to politics now more so
than they might have beating kovat and
being safe you know what I just got [ __ ]
for not wearing a mask in the coffee
yeah I mean talking about the mask ain't
[ __ ] the truth is that people are just
complacent we live in the freest place
ever right now right like we have no
idea none of the three of us have any
clue what real oppression is what real
not having to fight Authority is there
are plenty of other people that are
American that do know that that came
here from Eastern Europe or that's
parent parents survived communism or
Nazi Germany or a zillion other things
we have no idea when it starts to come
and I get a lot of emails from people
all over the world that are like it's
starting to feel like that yeah it's
starting to feel like the government's
are just coming and that's the thing the
idea that I would leave Cali I freaking
love it here my life is so good I have a
home and home studio and like I got
everything I want it all came together
here and for the last three weeks the
thing that I can't get out of my head is
maybe you gotta go yeah that sucks I
know it sucks but it's like but the stay
and fight thing is I think it means this
kind of fighting it has to with guys
like you and Rogan and Jordan Peterson
the smarter minds translating it to the
masses that's why listen I'm not a
quitter I'm not a quitter because I
would have to do something else right
like I've been gotten a lot of hate over
the years so I'm not a quitter but we
should learn something from Elon Musk
who's a brilliant man who was like no
I'm not doing that man if you do that
I'm taking all these employees and we're
going to Texas listen I bet they bent
the knee they they bend the knee I've
been on Fox News basically every day for
the last three weeks rallying against
newsom by name rallying against Garcetti
you know ever get any like sort of
response from them
no but I've also but by the way I
usually do it pretty respect him and
sometimes kind of jokey about them but
like I've invited them on my show I
would treat both of them exactly the
same way I've treated every other guest
which is with nothing but respect you
have a difficult job tell me your [ __ ]
tell me why or what you're doing that's
it that's what I give my explanation I
don't have one with Garcetti when he's
like yeah we're locking up for three
months that's it you got it by the LA
Times I'm like wait hold on why we beat
the curve that you told us maybe 15th I
know but then you don't give us any sort
of explanation and then they see the
backlash and then two minutes later
after that gets released he goes on CNN
he's like no I'm not saying it's gonna
be the same lockdown do think businesses
are still gonna stay open but it's just
the necessary steps like but no they
don't explain any he risks losing the
next election though I think these guys
are well he risks it he risks it if
enough people wake up but but so that's
the stay and fight question it's like
have these guys gone so bananas so off
the rails so drunk with power
that even in California enough people
are just like forget this I don't know
that maybe it is their cynical enough to
believe and I'm asking because I think I
know that like like an outfit like CNN
yeah when when they frame the amount of
death so though what this one guy who's
got a ballsy an outfit or alpha the way
they the way they
no an outfit oh they will they will have
a journalist on and he'll say the
equivalent of two towers at nine 911
yeah horrible that is dying every single
day and people still don't get it and
it's like is that what you're saying and
are you do you mind like having some
caveats around that how old are they are
we sure of that are they all being
tested there are all these questions
where you're like you're you're just you
are it's almost like they want this
lockdown to go on forever they do well
first off their ratings are up in the
midst of this because we're all trapped
at home so let's not the media is dead I
mean that that's an important thing to
just like we have to just say it and
know it the mainstream media is just
absolute dead CNN is the WWE it is I
mean I think that moment when you saw
that moment when Chris Cuomo walked out
of his basement yeah and they said well
he's been he's been in quarantine for
three weeks and here a guy and he had
the shivers and he chipped a tooth
because he had kovat and but and it's
like he comes up and he's sweating and
then he's here now to go was because he
was working out downstairs while he had
Kovac the whole thing's it's all fixed I
mean just a week before he had said it
was in quarantine for three weeks
turns out a week before he got into a
fight with a biker outside her house in
the Hamptons and there's but it's like
it's all made-up nonsense we are
watching WWE skits in front of us and
pretending it's real why don't people
get it no they saw on I'm on a book tour
right now I have done every freaking
podcast you can think of I've been on
every Fox show repeatedly I would go on
every single CNN show here I'm saying it
again I have not gotten one invite not
one end right from MSNBC they're just
afraid they just they just my only
caveat though would be I would I would
only do it live because I don't trust
them on the editorial side but Fox I go
on live they don't tell me to say
anything I was supposed to be on Perino
right before I got here but then this
Flynn story dropped so they canceled me
it so polarized aren't we in this
country it's just so [ __ ] well I think
most of us are like this yeah most
people were the fortunate one so you
know we're fortunate we're fortunate in
that we're not like completely partisan
crazy people wandering around thinking
that Nazis are hunting us down or that
half the country is evil or something
like that most people aren't you meet
most people it's like most people are
willing to admit they don't know
everything most people are willing to
admit that you know they
want to figure out a way to live with
other people but the media has just they
have just failed us just cuz that thing
says CNN and you remember that for 20
years ago doesn't mean anybody's like
even with foul Chee it's like take it
him into consideration when he came out
and goes you know he's been on the
record if this is nothing it's not a big
deal fast word month later this the
worst thing ever where mass prior that
don't wear masks none of it makes a that
he's wrong it's okay to say that you're
wrong he their projections were so far
wrong by the way somebody's also might
have to do with pouchy being very old
he's just protecting himself well I mean
there's an emotion sky you know yeah
he's up there you don't get in that
business stop being a very cautious
person well they give those that scale
of what was it 200 million a die yeah
and then you know $60,000 night well you
know they're just so far off I'm sure
somebody said 200 million though where
am i gavin newsom said we had were at
risk of having 87 or 90 95 percent of
California population being infected by
Kovac but but the thing is with them
gonna say if sorry no no they're gonna
say well the only reason that didn't
happen went into quarantine course okay
but then report but yeah how about
Sweden mouth these other states but how
about in quarantine what in even the
governor of New York came out and said
that what they've realized is by locking
down the family it's spreading like
crazy because they're all stuck together
so that being locked down the quarantine
doesn't make sense I think you can look
at it this way let's say we were truly
like in a dystopian future right now and
we knew for sure that 10% of Americans
were gonna die no one's saying this is
true so I'm giving you like I'm
ridiculously over-the-top scenario let's
say really they were like we know it
right now 10 percent of Americans are
gonna die
that's a crazy number that means every
one of every one of us would know
multiple people who died all that stuff
at some point even knowing that we'd
still have to start living again yeah
that's the thing I think they've tricked
us into thinking you know you keep
seeing this where they'll be like we
can't end this until the until there's a
vaccine there's no vaccine for the
common cold no I know life is about risk
right life is about risk you go out you
get punched you get into fight you get
hit by a car you I mean the video you
could have a freaking
you know around here a with as far as
deaths cuz you look at deaths over the
board from heart attacks to the flu the
common flu to all these other things
cholesterol obesity we're fine with
those but then you like you the numbers
of this which are much smaller and we're
not like over it's not that deadly how
about that it's not that deadly if
you're older look if you're older it
entropy if you're older it is and it is
more deadly than the flu from what I
understand but but either way the point
is we're gonna have they're gonna push
us to a place where good people are just
gonna be like forget this I'm gonna just
go ahead and live my life the idea that
right now
that I can't invite friends who are
young and healthy over for dinner I mean
I guess we could do it on the DL I feel
like I've been yeah yep look my hair is
a little shorter than it was the
stranger came into my house and clip my
hair told me how much he hated truck the
whole time and then left
hey Trump and still be against this
shutdown no a blanket shutdown of course
I don't have to be a trump supporter and
be for common sense right but this idea
that the anti Trump people they always
have to express it no matter what it's
like dude you have no idea what I think
about anything he didn't know who I am
doesn't even matter but like these
people that have to walk in and express
all of can you cut my hair yeah you got
a scissor right now you got to go on
your antitrump trevor like vegans no
knows but michael i producer here he got
a haircut his hair is a little shorter
than it was the other day too from
another guy and he has a trump
bobblehead in his apartment and the guy
came in and start ranting about Trump -
it's like these people could do your job
yeah do your job unless your job is to
hate Trump which then you get a job at
CNN yeah it really is true right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]